Judy Hopps is our main character yeah
well we're loud I expect you to
apologize for it bunnies in this world
are usually thought of to be carrot
farmers the bunnies are kind of small
and helpless
weirdly Judy wants to be a big city cop
CPD's first rabbit officer cops in the
downtown Zootopia are huge animals like
cape buffalo and the rhinoceros and
elephants and so her wanting to do this
was crazy everyone that she kind of
encounters thinks but what is she up to
but what what is with her but she has
this deep determination the second main
character is Nick and he's a fox I'm
here to ask you some questions about a
then they should have gotten a real cop
to solve it he's kind of a a jaded
Zootopia but we're under arrest for what
hooding of feelings people don't really
look upon foxes in Zootopia in a very
nice light I think they're shifty they
think they're slides you know he is Nick
himself is a con artist so he's kind of
playing right into everyone's perception
of what a fox is
no matter what type of animal you are
change starts with you if Judy believes
anyone can be anything nick is the
counterpart to that we're coming to a
place that says it's a shade of gray
that there is truth in both of those
statements but the most important thing
is don't let the world define who you
are especially with Judy and Nick like a
pretty animal and a predator who start
completely on opposite sides of the
animal world and learn to work together
we thought that was a great way to tell
the story and the message of the movie
through the characters I have 36 hours
left we can only solve it together what
I love about animated stories is we can
explore any type of topic and we can do
it in a way that kind of distance it
from our own world in a way because
we're telling it through the animal's
eyes but also is very relatable it's not
about how bad you want something it's
about what you are capable of we're
always trying to tell a story that's
funny and has emotion and makes our
audience fall in love with our
characters and that's the same between
live-action and animation but we then
get to create a world that nobody has
seen and I think that creates a whole
nother layer for the audience to come
and discover